je pense qu'il est important d'écouter
avec attention les personnes qui
s'opposent à la vaccination obligatoire
et notamment les soignants puisque ce
seront les premiers visés parce que ils
ont leur dignité
il exerce un métier et les mettre en
situation de choisir entre se faire
vacciner ou ne plus exercer ce métier je
trouve que c'est une grande pression
une atteinte bien sûr à leurs droits
alors comment raisonne les tribunaux
dans ce cas de figure c'est ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est une
question de proportionnalité est ce que
l'intérêt en jeu est supérieur et
justifie une telle une telle injonction
socialement collectivement vous évoquiez
la cgt qui a pris position
les syndicats vont ils réagir nous
sommes dans une situation où la
population dans son ensemble nous tous
sommes allés nerfs à fleur de peau après
les mois qui se sont passées on peut
imaginer que de manière très inattendue
impromptue une forte réaction sociale se
fasse jour
en réponse à une contrainte
supplémentaire de la part de l'état de
cette nature là je n'en sais rien et je
ne le souhaite pas on ne nous méprenons
pas je tu souhaites pas être de mauvais
augure mais je serai au gouvernement je
serai hypersensibles à la conséquence
sociale la réaction sociale d'une telle
contrainte supplémentaire
[Musique]